So let's expand on the reality that Donald
Trump is not the problem, but is a symptom.
I've said this before and I've never devoted
a whole segment to it that I can remember,
but I think it's an important time to discuss
this as we're starting to ramp up in the 2020
election and now we're getting beyond just
executive orders that could be quickly reversed
by the next president.
We're really now at a point at which there
has been irreversible harm by the presidency
of Donald Trump.
When we look today at Donald Trump's presidency
and we look at the United States and we look
at are increasingly laughable role in world
politics under Donald Trump, and we look at
countries around the world increasingly excluding
the United States from serious discussions
because Donald Trump just can't be the adult
in the room that our former president was.
Even if you disagreed with him on policy,
I understand that it can get really easy and
simple to just say, Donald Trump is the problem.
Trump is a problem, and I've told you every
time that I tell you that Donald Trump has
done something that's bad.
There's no question that Donald Trump is a
problem with Trump.
He really is.
Most importantly though, the end result of
the problem's not the problem in and of itself
at a kind of broader systemic level, and I
know that a lot of you already sort of have
an idea about some of the ways in which this
is true and could probably explain to me some
of the ways in which Donald Trump is a symptom
rather than the problem himself, but they're
actually more examples than we've ever discussed.
Number one, Trump, partially one partially
is an important word because of anti in pseudo
intellectual ism.
I've said this before, Trump didn't create
an electorate that is increasingly proud of
their ignorance and sees higher education
as inherently left wing nonsense and liberal
indoctrination.
Trump benefited from the American right, pushing
anti anti intellectual ism.
For decades, Trump benefited from a right
wing electorate that doesn't care about double
standards and hypocrisy and immorality on
the basis of their own moral code.
He benefited from that, but he didn't create
it.
Now I've given that example before and it's
not new and a lot of times people will write
to me, although they'll say, David, you're
just saying Trump.
Voters are stupid.
It's sort of an ad hominem.
It's not really an important and serious and
thorough analysis of what's going on.
Well, it's accurate and that's what I care
most about.
Even if some people don't like it, but it's
just one piece.
Let me give you another example of how Trump
is a symptom and not the problem in and of
itself.
Donald Trump has weaponized xenophobic, racist,
anti-immigrant nationalists, red meat, the
likes of which we've been seeing him throw
out to his followers since he announced his
candidacy back in 2015 I guess it was.
If there isn't already some of this repressed
desire for Trump's rhetoric, Trump throwing
that xenophobic, whatever red meat out isn't
going to work.
It's not going to help get him elected.
Donald Trump did not create racist anti-immigrant
nationalist sympathies in the American right.
What he was able to do is weaponize and coalesce
lots of what was being thought by American
right wingers but not typically said or not
always said, because they sort of realize
that there's a contingent of America, which
rightly is turned off by that type of rhetoric.
Those sympathies existed before Donald Trump.
Donald Trump didn't create those sympathies
and if they didn't exist, Trump wouldn't have
been able to take advantage of them.
So this is another way in which Donald Trump
is a symptom of the problem and an end result,
not the problem in and of itself, but let's
keep going.
Okay.
Because very often the analyses stop here
and so far it's just been examples of how
the right has fomented the circumstances that
led to Trump and they have.
But the left is not totally innocent here
either.
The left as a really bad alternative to the
right for a lot of the last 20 years also
enabled Donald Trump to win.
I'm not blaming Democrats.
Okay.
Understand what it is that, I mean, the Democratic
Party has been a slightly left of center party
overall.
Okay.
There are exceptions overall for the last
two decades or more, the Democratic Party
has at the national level, by and large, been
a slightly left of Center Party.
The DNC and the Democratic Party Corporate
Democrats, so to speak, have unsuccessfully
tried to compromise with an American right
wing is that doesn't compromise.
They've played the sort of milk toast slightly
to the left of Republican's alternative for
decades with some exceptions.
Of course, they have mostly still been part
of the neo liberal centrist status quo force
that is only recently sort of started to wake
up to the reality that we've got to deal with
systemic inequality.
Health care needs to be radically changed
at a systemic level.
The foreign policy of the United States needs
a complete and total overhaul.
We need to rethink the economy.
We need to rethink all sorts of stuff so when
the alternative to Republicans has been for
decades, mostly a democratic party that is
basically a slightly more progressive but
widely impotent alternative that apologizes
for being slightly left and often runs as
Republican light.
That has also helped millions of voters say,
let's just give Trump a shop.
Okay?
When both Democratic and republican presidents
for a long time haven't improved on the fundamental
economic frustrations that most Americans
have other than dealing with it around the
edges for the lower and middle class, of course,
that's going to get some people to say, what
the hell?
Let's just try Donald Trump.
Now, this is not a defense of Trump voters.
This is not a defensive right wing ideology.
This is not a criticism of every individual
Democrat or policy idea from the Democratic
Party.
What I'm pointing out is the reality that
the right has done a really job of creating
the conditions in which Donald Trump could
do what he did by appealing to these base,
uh, of unsophisticated anti intellectual,
uh, movements and ideas of the right, but
the Democratic Party hasn't been left enough
or strong enough or principled enough to be
the obvious right choice to more of America
over a totally ignorant clown like Trump.
Now I know a lot of you will write in and
say, David, a lot of those right wing voters
are so ignorant and so ideological and they
just care about abortion.
Uh, the evangelicals anyway, that it doesn't
matter what the Democratic Party does, either
way, they weren't going to vote for Democrats.
I agree that that applies to a lot of the
Republican party.
But this election came down to 77,000 votes
in three states.
There is no way that you are going to convince
me and I don't think there is an empirical
case to be made that if the Democratic Party
didn't seem like, uh, uh, what, what it has
been for the last several decades, that 77,000
votes wouldn't have gone a different way if
it was made abundantly clear all along that
this is not Republican lite.
It's not a slightly more pro social version
of Republicans at the national level.
So Trump voting out should happen.
Trump either has a year and a half left or
five and a half years left.
We don't know.
Eventually Trump's going to be gone.
There's going to be real damage that Donald
Trump did, which the next person, whoever
it is, is going to have to clean up.
If Trump gets reelected in 2020 it'll be more
damage than if he's removed in 2020.
But there's no undoing the reality that we
now know you can weaponize all of the worst
instincts and ideas and sympathies of the
American right and conservatives are to blame
for most of it.
But the Democratic Party is not innocent here.
And it's really, really important that we
not forget that.
I hope you're listening carefully and realize
I'm not doing the both sides are the same.
I'm not doing both sides are equally to blame
because they're not, but the democratic establishment
is not innocent in the rise of Trump.
If you look at their behavior over the last
20 to 30 years, the circumstances that led
to Trump are many and democrats have a piece
of that responsibility.
Tell me where I'm wrong.
Tell me what I'm missing and make sure to
subscribe to both the Youtube Channel and
the podcast to support the work that we do.
A lot of behind the scenes pictures from my
trip to Los Angeles last week, which included
an appearance on the Joe Rogan program.
Follow the show on Instagram at David Pakman
show and follow me while you're there
at David.
Yeah,
Scott
Pack